tiefer und breiter sollte die Elbe
werden damit die Container Riesen der
neuesten Generation den Hamburger Hafen
auch voll beladen anlaufen können doch
der Plan geht nicht auf seit der letzten
Elbvertiefung sammelt sich immer mehr
Schlick in der Fahrrinne und wird so
Gefahr für den Schiffsverkehr auch für
die Fähre zwischen Glückstadt und
Wischhafen
[Musik]
der Albtraum jedes Schiffsführers die
Fähre ist trotz reduzierter Beladung vor
dem Anleger wie scharfen aufgrund
gelaufen und wieder frei zu kommen lässt
Kapitän Kilian die drei LKW auf Deck
versetzten eine sogenannte stromerbe hat
das Wasser aus der Elbe gedrückt und
ungeheure schlickmassen freigelegt sie
meinte die sich überall ablagern die
Folge das Fahrwasser wird flacher
ich kann das ja nun beurteilen seit über
30 Jahren
fahre ich hier
und ich habe das so Step by Step
mitbekommen dass jede Elbvertiefung für
uns immer etwas schlechteres war was für
kleine Fähren gilt gilt auch für große
Schiffe lotsenverbände schlagen Alarm
Container riesen müssten bereits Slalom
fahren um Havarien durch Untiefen zu
vermeiden damit ist das eingetreten
wovor Umweltverbände im Streit um die
rund 1,2 Milliarden Euro teure fahren
Anpassung immer gewarnt hatten
sehr flacher Fluss ursprünglicher Weise
und durch die sehr starke Vertiefungen
in den letzten Jahren Jahrzehnten hat
die Strömung auch sehr stark zugenommen
und nimmt eben alle Sedimente aus der
Nordsee und vom Ufer mit sich mit reißt
das mit und die Elbe selber hat gar
nicht genug Kraft und das mit dem App
Strom wieder raus zu transportieren
deswegen lagert sich das alles ab für
dreistellige Millionenbeträge im Jahr
lassen die Behörden dagegen anbaggern
mit geringem Erfolg die geplante Tiefe
wird aktuell um einen Meter verfehlt für
die Container riesen weiterhin zu wenig
Wasser unter Kiel voll beladen nach
Hamburg zu kommen
genau das aber war das Ziel als im
Beisein des damaligen
Bundesverkehrsministers scheuer im
Sommer 2019 die Bauarbeiten offiziell
begannen der Hamburger Hafen hat über
die letzten zehn Jahre wegen der
fehlenden fahren Anpassung über 25%
Marktanteil gegenüber sein Wettbewerbern
in Holland und Antwerpen verloren das
eine Menge das wieder aufzuholen geht
jetzt los zuvor hatten die Hansestadt
und Umweltverbände fast zwei Jahrzehnte
vor Gericht um die Elbvertiefung
gewonnen Naturschützer sahen vor allem
die flachen Uferbereiche gefährdet
Lebensraum von Jungfischen und Habitat
des seltenen schierlings Wasser Fenchel
erst Anfang 2017 gab das
Bundesverwaltungsgericht in Leipzig
unter Auflagen schließlich grünes Licht
für die insgesamt 9 Anpassung der
Fahrrinne
doch die gesteckten Ziele werden bis
heute nicht erreicht was die zuständigen
Behörden auf zdf-anfrage mitteilen ist
Behörden Deutsch für noch mehr Bagan
nach einer umpriorisierung und
Verstärkung der Unterhaltsleistungen
werden möglichst schnell die
planfestgestellten Tiefgänge für die
Schifffahrt wieder zur Verfügung
gestellt
wann das ist und wie viel das kostet
ungewiss nicht wenige Experten halten
die Elbvertiefung bereits für gescheite
sie ist auf jeden Fall aber ein
ökonomisches und vor allem auch
ökologisches Desaster
im Sommer wird ein 40 Kilometer langes
sauerstoffloch rund um den Hamburger
Hafen gemessen eine Todeszone für
Wasserlebewesen wir begleiten damals
Lothar Buckow einen der letzten
Elbfischer im geht nur noch wenig in die
Reusen und wenn dann sind es ein paar
Aale stimmt früher der Brot und
Butterfisch der Hamburger Fischer fängt
der kaum noch
das ist ja auf der ganzen Elbe ganz
schwierig geworden stimmt überhaupt zu
kriegen also besonders hier vor den
Toren Hamburgs wo die stehen immer
gleich haben und wo massig stimmt
gewesen sind geht jedes Jahr durch
Sauerstoff noch alles kaputt die Ursache
dafür ist aus seiner Sicht eindeutig in
der trüben Brühe können Wasserpflanzen
keinen Sauerstoff mehr produzieren das
liegt eben an dieser ständigen bakerei
also wir haben hier manchmal sieben acht
große große Hopper die hier den Fleck
aufnehmen und den weiter runterbringen
manchmal auch nur 15 km weiter
runterbringen und dann wieder verklappen
und das hat dann zur Folge dass der
schlägt eigentlich nie zur Ruhe kommt um
die weniger erfolgreiche
kreislaufbaggerei zu beenden will
Hamburgs rot grüne Landesregierung den
schlägt nun weit draußen in der Nordsee
verklappen aber auch vor der zur
Hansestadt gehören Insel Schaar
Vogelschutzgebiet und Teil des
Nationalparks hatten mehr Pläne gegen
die die neue eben als rot-grüne
niedersächsische Regierung notfalls
klagen will der Landtag in Niedersachsen
ist einstimmig aufgefordert alle
Möglichkeiten auch rechtliche zu nutzen
um die niedersächsischen Interessen zu
waren wir haben ein gemeinsames Feld
naturerbewattenmeer da darf es keine
Belastungen geben und wir halten eben
die Sediment Verklappung Forscher hören
für eine erhebliche Belastung das
Dilemma mit dem Schlick ist auch eines
der Hamburger grünen was geht vor
Wirtschaftsinteressen oder Umweltschutz
sie sehen die Schuld bei
Vorgängerregierungen in Bund und Ländern
das ist das was wir als Grüne schon
immer und lange kritisiert haben dass
man mit viel Energie aus diesem
Bundesländern aus dem Bund die Leute
fahren Anpassung vorangetrieben hat
seiner Zeit aber gar kein Konzept hatte
wo man eigentlich mit den Sedimenten hin
will und das fällt uns jetzt auf die
Füße die Zeit aber drängt der Hafen ist
das wirtschaftliche Herz der Hansestadt
es muss weiter schlagen das sei im
Interesse des ganzen Landes und deswegen
dürfte der Bund Hamburg mit dem
schlickproble nicht alleine lassen im
Kern geht es ja um eine
Bundeswasserstraße und die
Bundeswasserstraße muss unterhalten und
freigehalten werden für den den
Schiffsbetrieb und ich glaube dass der
Bund hier derjenige ist der allein ein
Tisch holen muss und im Sinne der der
deutschen Wirtschaft und damals oberste
Regal zu greifen weil darum geht es
wirklich hier zu Lösungen zu kommen und
diese Blockaden die es gibt aufzulösen
die Elbe aber habe den Wettlauf um tief
Verbreiter schneller schon verloren
warnen Umweltschützer die Elbers
Ökosystem ist an ihrem Ende tatsächlich
muss man gerade sagen die Grenze ist
erreicht ist natürlich Machbaren das ist
ein tiedefluss wir haben ein
mündungsgewässer aber wir haben Sie
einmal zu oft ausgebaggert das muss man
leider so sagen und jetzt rechts sich
das und die Elbe sagt halt hier geht's
nicht weiter oft nicht mehr weiter
kommen auch die Fahrgäste und Betreiber
der Elbfähre zwischen Glückstadt und wir
schaffen wegen des ungelösten schlägt
Problems gibt es stundenlange
Wartezeiten weil die Schiffe nicht mehr
voll beladen werden können das kostet
Nerven und bares Geld
wir kalkulieren derzeit mit mit einem
Schaden dieses Jahr von grob einer
Million Euro das letztlich zusammen aus
Ticket Umsatz der wegfällt durch Schäden
an den Schiffen also höhere Abnutzung
der Propeller eines der Schiffe hat 10
cm am Propeller dieses Jahr verloren und
auch höherer Treibstoffverbrauch war
einfach die Schiffe mehr Treibstoff
brauchen wenn sie mit wenig Wasser sich
quasi durch die Süden
mit geschickten Manövern kann Kapitän
Kilian den sprichwörtlichen Karren
derweil gerade noch einmal aus dem Dreck
ziehen nun will er seine nautischen
Fähigkeiten aber nicht weiter ausreizen
jetzt stellen wir ein und ja und nichts
geht mehr für mindestens sieben Stunden
ist die einzige Elbquerung zwischen dem
Hamburger Elbtunnel und der Mündung im
Wattenmeer unterbrochen bis zum nächsten
Hochwasser wenn die Fähre wieder die
berühmte Handbreit Wasser und am Kiel
hat